مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره
من مدينه مارسيليا الفرنسيه حيث يحتشد
الالاف في تظاهرات متجدده ضد تعديل قانون
التقاعد حيث لاقى حديث الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون عن قانون اصلاح التقاعد
لقى ردود فعل غاضبه وممدده كذلك وذلك بعد
حديثه للمره الاولى منذ اندلاع الاحتجاجات
عن اصراره عن على تطبيق اصلاح نظام
التقاعد
المشاهدين في هذا اللقاء على اهميه دخول
اصلاح نظام التقاعد حيز التنفيذ بحلول
نهايه هذا العام واعتبر انه مشروع ضروري
وذلك خلال مقابله تلفزيونيه
وبينما لا تزال تتواصل الاحتياجات في
الشوارع كما نتابع في هذه الصور تجهز
النقابات اذا في هذا اليوم
لاضراب عام وتظاهرات في تحرك وصفته وسائل
اعلام بالخميس الاسود في قسمين من الشاشه
هذه المظاهرات في مناطق مختلفه في باريس
على يمين الشاشه ومنطقه مارسيليا على
اليسار الشاشه وهو ما وصفه الاعلام بيوم
الخميس الاسود الذي حشدت له النقابه
الفرنسيه احتجاجا على
تعديل نظام التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس
الفرنسي